So in cycle 13,
what happens is this ROB2 instruction
finally writes its result.
This result is 12.
We mark now this instruction as done and
the value of 12 will be broadcast
under the name of ROB2.
So now these instructions
here are waiting for
their inputs and this one here
matches that I'm waiting for
ROB2 value, so it captures it here.
This is the first operand
that we're waiting for.
The second operand was already
there since awhile ago.
So this instruction, which is the ROB4
instruction is no longer waiting for
anything.
It can actually dispatch in
this cycle 13 and in cycle 14,
the fourth instruction begins executing.
None of the other instructions are
waiting for ROB2, so this concludes what
happens when we broadcast the value
in cycle 13 for the ROB2 instruction.
What now happens is again, in cycle 14,
we begin executing this multiplication.
And because it has begun
executing in this cycle,
this reservation station
is already free.
It was freed when we dispatched
in the previous cycle.
So I'm going to note that
this multiplication of 12 and
13, which gives us 36 is going to
end up in ROB4, eventually here, but
it's not going to be done
until 10 cycles from cycle 14.
So, it's going to be in cycle 24
that we try to write the result.
These two instructions
still are waiting for
ROB4 and ROB5 instructions and
this happens beyond cycle 14.
So in cycles 15, 16, etc.
Nothing really happens.
In fact, nothing will happen until we
have another broadcasted for result and
the results we will broadcast
eventually going to be in 42 and 24.
24 comes first, so
let's see what happens in cycle 24.
In cycle 24, the fourth structure
will broadcast the result.
This is the multiplication here.
So what's going to happen is the value
of 36 is going to be broadcast under
the name of ROB4.
This instruction is waiting for ROB4,
so it's going to capture the value
of 36 and mark that we are no
longer waiting for this operand.
This instruction actually, now it
doesn't wait for anything anymore.
So in cycle 25, the subtract
is going to start executing.
Meanwhile, our ROB4 instruction
gets marked as done.
Basically, this value or 36 that was
broadcast gets kind of deposited here
and marked as done in the ROB and this
kind of concludes what happens with this
multiplication instruction as far
as precommit stuff is concerned.
It cannot commit,
yet again, because we need all of
these to commit before it can commit.
So, it's still going to be at least
cycle 43 before we consider committing
anything.
In the cycle 24, however, the ROB5
instruction will be dispatched and
it will begin again
executing in cycle 25.
So let's just move to cycle 25.